When Star Wars: The Last Jedi hits theaters
on December 15, it's guaranteed to be one
of the biggest box office hits of the year,
if not all time.
So why are some theaters flat-out refusing
to screen the movie at all?
According to a report by The Wall Street Journal,
Disney is imposing harsh financial requirements
on the theaters they'll partner with to screen
The Last Jedi — terms that many theater
owners are calling the "most onerous they
have ever seen."
Typically, movie studios take 55 to 60 percent
of ticket sales for a first run film, with
that percentage dropping the longer the movie
is out.
However, as one film insider told The Wall
Street Journal, Disney is currently "in the
most powerful position any studio has ever
been in" thanks to the fact that the last
film in the series, 2015's Star Wars: The
Force Awakens, is by far the biggest domestic
box office hit in history.
As a result, Disney is asking for an unprecedented
65 percent of the box office take from all
participating theaters.
Needless to say, the studio has significantly
altered the usual deal.
"I have altered the deal! Pray I don't alter it any further."
"This deal is getting worse all the time."
But wait, the deal does get worse!
Any theater that wants to show The Last Jedi
also has to agree to screen it for a full
four weeks at a minimum in their biggest auditorium.
Plus, Disney is also imposing an uncommon
penalty for violating these terms.
Should Disney deem any theater to be in violation
of the agreement, the agreement says that
Disney is then allowed to take an additional
5 percent of ticket sales from the theater
— meaning that for four weeks, 70 percent
of all money earned from The Last Jedi in
a theater would go straight to Disney.
Violations, according to Disney, would include
pulling even one screening from a theater's
schedule, or using marketing materials for
the movie before Disney gives the go-ahead.
While these terms still are harsh for massive
chains like AMC or Cinemark, the conditions
really hurt smaller theaters, serving small
populations.
And some independent theater operators are
considering fighting back by boycotting The
Last Jedi entirely.
One cinema owner who operates a single-screen
theater noted that in his small town, everyone
who wanted to see The Last Jedi would see
it in the first two weeks, leaving the owner
stuck playing the movie for the last two weeks
to what would eventually be an empty room.
For this trouble, the theater would keep only
35 percent of the increasingly meager profits
from it all — or 30 percent, if Disney decides
they broke a rule.
Considering the record-breaking success of
The Force Awakens, it's easy to see why Disney
would want more money.
But as crazy as it sounds, it might actually
make more financial sense for some theaters
not to screen The Last Jedi at all rather
than give in to Disney's demands.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!